monsieur bergougnoux bonsoir reste que
le président de la sncf considère ce
soir que ces négociations sont un échec
comme le considèrent les syndicats bah
si vous entendez par là que la rencontre
de ce soir n'a pas arrêté la grève
oui bien sûr il faut bien comprendre
l'origine de la crise que nous
traversons et apparaît très clairement à
travers les déclarations que nous avons
entendu il s'agit d'un amalgame entre
les inquiétudes des cheminots sur
l'avenir de leur régime de retraite et
que leur inquiétude sur l'avenir de
l'entreprise qui s'incarne travers le
contrat de plan sur le premier poids je
n'ai pu que rappeler les déclarations
clarifie catrice pour fait différemment
du gouvernement hier sur le second point
le contrat de plan nous avançons vous
avancez mais les syndicats appellent à
une poursuite de la grève
qu'est-ce qui pourrait débloquer la
situation à votre avis je crois que la
question du contrat de plan on reste
malgré tout essentiel et j'ai pu ce soir
remettre aux organisations syndicales un
avant projet qui traite déjà deux
questions importantes
la pérennité de l'entreprise de son
statut le service public
et puis aussi tendre le cou au passage à
cette affaire des 6000 kilomètres de
lignes que l'on va supprimer et qui
n'est qu'imaginaire mais surtout j'ai pu
dire vrai je confirmerai dans deux jours
lorsque le mécanisme d endettement par
lequel l'état accompagnera nos efforts
sera précisée j'ai aujourd'hui la
conviction que ce contrat tampon
entreprise est une vraie chance à saisir
grâce à l'aide de l'état si nous prenons
notre destin en main nous pouvons
redresser durablement l'entreprise
monsieur bergougnoux je vous remercie
joli